[موسيقى]
طبعا في الاونه الماضيه طبعا كانت هناك
مذكره تفاهم مشترك بين دول المغاربيه تونس
والجزائر والمغرب وموريتانيا
لاعتماد الواجب طبق الكسكسي في قائمه
التراث العربي للدول هذه ليبيا لم تكون من
ضمن هذا الملف نظرا لعدم توقيع اتفاقيه
صون الثلاثي الثقافي غير مادي من الدوله
الليبيه طبعا حذف في نفسنا هذا الموضوع
فتنادينا وكان تحركنا كلها يعني شعبي
ومدني بيدافع وطني
يعني
قمنا باحياء او
باطلاق يوم اسمها يوم الكسكسي الليبي من
خلال هذا اليوم يعني نبعث رسائل
للمسؤولين في ليبيا والمسؤولين في
اليونسكو
مجسدهم
ويجعلهم في ثقه بين طبق الكسكسي هو ليبي
الهويه
ليبيا لها حصه مثل باقي دول المغاربيه
[موسيقى]
انا زي اي سيده ليبيه نحب الطبخ ونحب
اسرتي نقدم للوجبات اللي يحبوها والاطباق
المميزه الليبيه التقليديه
والحمد لله اني اصلي من صفر الجمعه اراده
يعني
بعيد
اللي جددنا اليوم ما شاء الله يعني
المجهود واضح اللي عاملينه البلديه صبراته
وبارك الله فيهم واحنا جينا من بعيد
وسمعنا في اخر لحظه بالاعلام وجانا
بسياراتنا الخاصه حتى فاتتنا الاتوبيسات
ولكن احنا مبسوطين وسعداء جدا بهذه
الاحتفاليه وهذا المهرجان
[موسيقى]